foreign
[Music]
MD PhD from University of Nebraska
Medical Center uh today I'd like to
present our
research about a concept of Uncle Golgi
and er stress in the development and
progression of prostate cancer but first
of all I would like to acknowledge
organizers for such opportunity to share
our uh all recent data and some
unpublished data which directly related
to the topic okay Uncle Junior are
treasure drivers or prostate cancer
progression so just few words about
prostate cancer as you know uh in
prostate cancer still unfortunately
leading in top 10 cancer Berets of new
cancer cases and unfortunately it's
still as a second place among cancer
related to death
endoplasmic reticulum stress it's one of
the evolutionary conserved process which
occurs when unfolded proteins accumulate
in the endoplasmic reticulum which lead
to
launching evolutionary conserve process
unfolded protein response so ubr has a
two main aims on one side it's
expressive genes and to to enhance
protein folding capacity of the ER on
the other hand it's a facilitation
accelerate ER Associated protein
degradation to remove misfolding
proteins and prevent apoptolysis there
are three main branches on ER stress
and first of all in the beginning is the
grp78 which is a precursor of main
chaperones and you can see three
branches of er stress one of them are
every one perk and 1856 so ir1
responsible for or
um for production of an expression of
alarm genes a perk uh mostly responsible
for Activation of adaptation genes and
Atif C6 among them they're only one from
these three branches which has direct
relationship with Golgi morphology so
normally it relocates to the Golgi to be
cleaved by s1p and STP proteases
inclusive C6 should move into the
nucleus activating again several genes
which responsible for employ unfolded
approach in response
uh
so we're going to come to the ersters in
cancer there's a two side of the same
coin so on one side you can see that uh
cancer cells itself
um er stress associated with image to
one down regulation it Associates
metastases angiogenesis resistance to
therapy and survival under hypoxia on
the other hand ear stress in myeloid
cells associated with deficient antigen
presentation it's suppressed uh
phenotype of production of pro uh
activate proteum or genetic cytokines
and basically uh broadly speaking ER
stressing myeloid cells associated with
pronogenic inflammation
now just few words about prostate cancer
and gold relationships the Golgi
apparatus it's a main station of
post-translational modification and the
morphology of Golgi is maintained by
gold genes which is Golgi matics
proteins
there are different magic Sports in
localizing the Seas Golgi in the middle
Golgi is a trans Golgi but that
composition architecture it's one story
so to function properly Golgi fulfill of
Resident proteins which is glycosyl
transfer as glycosidasis and kinases if
you look at the structure of
um glycosyl transfer as you can see
that's mostly it's a large catalytic
domain short stable region short
transmember domain and very short
cytoplasmic tests now whereas the short
cytoplasmic tail is critical for many
functions overlap is coverage they
function in retention in um and
transportation but most significantly
which we're talking about this story
it's uh docking ducking to the Golgi
membranes so uh there are two duck
inside and this is Golgi one is
presented by giantine which is the
largest gold geomatics Protein that's
the name can giant comes from the
because it's the largest Golgi protein
it's around 400 KD which support
presumably was suggested to be a floppy
large cytoplasmic domain
alternative uh dock inside represented
by dimers grab65 and G13 but there's a
two type of vesicles which carry Golgi
glycosyl transfer others on the one side
is Giant in docking enzymes on the other
side is gm130 graph 65. so we look at
the
three types of protein which can can
darken the gold you can see number one
these proteins using giant as a docking
site number two this protein using gm1
Theory and you can see there is a link
between genital and gm1 Theory but there
is also uh protease number three which
technically is the outside of the Golgi
if you look at the Horizon side
fragmentation of Golgi membranes
associated with giant in monomerization
and those enzymes cannot be docked on
the Golgi and they stain behind the
Golgi and retaining the plasma critical
or cytoplasm however protein number two
can still localized in the gold you're
using GM 130 because dimerization of
Gene 130 Graphics is not affected so and
but that monomerization of genetime
brings opportunity for proteins number
three which now can technically be dark
and the Golgi which normally never
happen
uh our analysis of giant insensitive and
Gene 130 sensitive enzymes reveal that
there is interesting Tendencies so giant
insensitive enzymes turns out like have
a dive basic KK RR or KR motifs however
in terminal tale of Gene one third is
sensitive enzymes it's a right panel you
can see it's mostly it can test
primarily different combinations of
hydrophobic motifs
uh with the most widely used model of
quick uh ER stress is peripheral
induced rapid air stress within one hour
using as a low dosage concentration and
that results in uh in phenomenon when
Golgi collapse so you don't see Golgi
morphology Golds just collapse into the
ER but most increasingly you can see
that giant in dimer so figure number
figure a you can see getting monomerized
after prevailing a treatment so this is
a data showing when you remove and you
can send a panel C when you remove bread
and a you do Prevail the name wash out
Giant in them are coming back and you
can send the panel G that most of the
giant team uh monomers detected in the
in the plasmic reticulum when you treat
with this drug so in other words this
slide just provide an idea that uh Golgi
disorganization and er stress associated
with was Giant in monomerization and
then to prove that we proceed
proximately ligation I say and you can
see that we use two in the panel C on
the right side you can see we use
different combinations of antigenetian
antibody and then technically if we
believe the gelatin is a floppy then we
cannot detect by proximity ligation as
say signal between these two proteins so
proximity ligation I say it's a very
nice tool which can detect protein
protein interaction within 60 nanometers
and otherwise we use a different rabbit
and mouse anti-barrassing gain giant
which is which eventually have different
epitops and you can see if they are
really floppy you cannot detect pla but
we are able in indicating that gerontin
is rather flexible has ex that has a it
has a hook domain it has a hook
structure rather than
uh floppy so but it would have
information and golgi's collapse you can
see monomerization of giantine
associated with uh reduction of pla
signal indicating that gin instead of
extent extent of flex composition we
have now extended morphology of giant
instruction in other words
monomerization of giantine associated
with its extension of its domains so and
in the bottom you can see Atomic Force
microscopy analysis when we can see
dimer size in the MSO control versus
Brazilian a and that's Western blood
data again uh showing
um again that dimer present in DMSO but
not anymore in not anymore in Brazilian
hatred itself
and this is a summary of uh Golgi
biogenesis again when you remove
bravilion a Golgi restores back and we
just um this is a paper we recently
published indicating that formation of
fusion of
Ernest and Golgi membranes so
Reformation of Golgi memory associated
with dimerization of giantine through
its c-terminal and disulfate bond so
transmembrane domain making by
disulfable information it brings two
Golgi membranes together that's another
Fusion is actually linked to giantine
damerization and there as you can see
rap6 a g t pH which assist Giant in this
process
and basically it recalls um when you
just time
um a shoelaces it's pretty much same you
pull in two two shoelaces from different
sites and then Rob them making solid and
strong composition of your shoes so
that's pretty much identical process and
two two monitors of giant insert Diamond
radiation pulling Golgi membranes
together so giant in other words it's
critical for critical for Golgi
biogenesis and any ER stress associated
with go to this organization associated
with giant in the dimerization and
restoration of Golgi is always
associated with giant in Diamond
radiation so now it comes to the process
of cancer cells you can see a low
pathogen cap cells which is low Advanced
prostate cancer has a compact nice frag
Golgi it's a perineuclear space which
has a ribbon-like composition uh but
look at the high passage all in cup
which is Advanced prostate cancer cell
and PCC resource you can see for
augmentation of the Golgi if you look at
the tissue you can see normal prostate
this is a compact Golgi and this is a
fragmented Golgi in grade three and even
more severe fragmentation in grade five
again so all these negative indications
that a progression or prostate cancer
associate with uh Golgi disorganization
and importantly this Golgi
disorganization associated with giant in
monomerization like I said remember
there's a two type you can you can be
docked on genetime graph65 and g130 the
problem is in Allen cup when giant is
still dimer when it comes to progression
of cancer you can see giant in
monomerization no any dimer detected
however you can see on the bottom panel
on Western blood there's a
diamondization of graph 65 and you can
even detect tetramas another word
monomerization of genes associated with
increase of oligomerization of graph 65
and g130 proteins so in other words
that's for augmented Golgi still
maintain morphology by alternative
golgiomatics proteins in this case is
presented by grab 65 in GM 130 and
here's a quantification of monomer dimer
and damage tetramer
for these proteins
uh
and proximate delegation I say you can
see Nolan camp in PC3 when when you can
detect Giant in diners in Ln Cup in
pieces you can detect little if any
dimers again this is a comp indicating
that uh go to this organization and er
stress potential in in prostate cancer
cells associate with uh lose of giantine
dynamic structure how that affects on a
glycosylation and you know the abnormal
glycosylation cancer it's one of the
Hallmark of cancer and those
promotes static glycans are important
for
[Music]
um
metastases for angiogenesis for growing
prostate tumor and specifically for
progression for metastasis and you can
see it's a normal Golgi you can see all
glycosylation and that formation green
arrows indicate uh bronchogenic Pathways
which actually non-essential and more
blacker or indicate dominant Pathways
you can see that mostly
um compact Golgi all these Black Arrow
indicate dominant Pathways when you can
you can create structures which has no
any horrible harm to the cells they are
not oncogenic however Golgi
fragmentation associate with
[Music]
um
with activation that non-essential
Pathways now you can see the Green Arrow
there's a activation of uh different
proncogenics uh green arrows or it's a
normal Pathways but Black Arrow indicate
many formation of many bronchogenic
glycon Epitaph like style tantages thin
antigens cholesterol structure all these
acetylation proteins silent antigensity
antigen all these are really significant
for uh as you can see on the bottom side
I lose X so these are the bronchogenic
glycoepitopes which really is
significant for cancer metastases so
fragmentation of Golgi and its
phenomenon for many different kind of
cancer groups or fragmentation and
golgiene and prostate pancreatic cancer
breast cancer brain cancer ovarian
cancer so uh normally Golgi can fragment
in two different cases if it's apoptosis
or mitosis however you can see that
fragmentation of the Golgi in in in
cancer which we call oncagology
associated with upregulation of
cellulation activation of different
energy phases motor proteins margin and
hypoptotic kinases and when it comes to
the ER stress in cancer which is a
well-known phenomenon so now when it's
time to say that there is no ER stress
without going to this organization and
also there is no golgiate
disorganization without the assets you
cannot affect Golgi structure without
without
facilitating your stress and vice versa
you cannot induce ER stress and keep
your Golgi compact so so er sketching
goji's organizations this has two sides
of the same coin
um so the basic idea is would be clear
just inhibit UPR and you can block one
of the significant driver of prostate
cancer progression however within many
years there was a posit uh concept when
you can uh increase consistent severity
of air stress and induce apopters indeed
if you inducer 13 process cancer cells
you can kill those cells by by
hypothesis but there is a there is one
interesting aspect and I can tell you
why it doesn't make sense to me so
basically this is basic information you
have certain prostate cancer an
activation of adhd6 another two branches
of UPR and ir1 has been shown in wide
range of solid and butter malignancies
and several studies implicated
here says in European development of
um dangerous type of prostate cancer
which called castration resistant
prostate cancer when Androgen ablation
therapy which normally used in a
chemotherapy doesn't work so this is a
this kind of
um tremendous type of
um
prostate cancer progression so again the
presence of chronic air stress but
enhanced activity to 1866 is well
documented but mechanisms was not when
it comes to the point why doesn't make
sense to activate air stress so it comes
with a constant tumor hemoretogenity and
tumoretogenity come from genetic
features So within the same patients
with the same glistens score you can see
different expression of Androgen
receptor and let's take a look at
Androgen receptor so this is a normal
process you can see expression of
Androgen receptor in the nucleus which
is red uh quite a bit equal but when it
comes to the cancer you can see that
some of the cells highly Express
androgenerational cells are not so blue
is just nucleus which has known Androgen
receptor at all
um when it comes to the integrine
Hallmark of cancer progression you can
see that uh Aria with high expression of
intagnets which is red and area with
lows in other words there's a large
tumor heterogeneity and when it comes to
the
um heterogeneity from the point of er
stress you can see that progression
associated with activation of ATF C6 you
can see more 86 in high Gleason score
patients and you can see grp78 signal
increase in progression of prostate
cancer but if you look at the staining
of uh adfcc this is a log listen score
low aggressive you can see
um there's very small amount of ATF C6
in the nucleus however country in high
glucern score in high Advanced prostate
cancer you can see different population
of ad66 cells which has high expression
of 1866 and cells which don't Express at
all so let's say you uh you're gonna
induce your stress in this Source
apparently you're going to kill that
cells but but in other cells which don't
have VR stress you're going to activate
your stress and highly likely you're
going to activate and you're gonna
you're gonna you're gonna waking up a
dormant cell so having a positive effect
from you already expecting so in other
words you can you can basically activate
cancer by inducing excessive VR stress
that's a whole point
um why we believe it's not it's not
appropriate but we believe instead we
like to Target in and block your stress
so this is our concept of Golgi
fragmentation we recently shown that uh
Goji fragmentation associated with
translocation of GSK is to be kindness
from Golgi to the cytoplasm which leads
to activation of h.6 and that the
acetylene HSP 90 which finally leads to
trans activation of Androgen receptor
but what we've shown also recently that
uh crossword cancer cells have Elegant
mechanisms without activation of ear
stress as you can see and normally like
I said ATF C6 is go to the Golgi cleared
by s1p and s2b proteases include pv58
AFC shift to the nucleus to activate UPR
genes but what happens in advanced
prostate cancer Golgi is disorganized
and so on P and s2parate as is not
anymore in the gold years they shift
into the ER whereas they can cleavage
fc6 the so that translocation accelerate
ER stress so in other words Advanced
prostate cancer cells employ very
elegant mechanisms of Auto activation of
er stress so when it comes to the
prostate cancer and changes in Golgi so
we believe that
um integrines which actually
overexpressed in many different cancers
including prostate so that Integrity is
as you know uh it has been shown maybe
you heard that activation of Integrity
is expression on the plasma membrane
always associated with the mg85 mediated
glycosylation so in fact this is
critical for externalization
intervalization of prostate cancer for
the adhesion and currently using
monoclonal antibiotic to zoom up it was
very promising but so a molecular
antibody didn't show any frequency in
five years survival of patients
unfortunately we believe because
molecular antibody can block anti can
block Integrity as a cell surface that
they cannot interfere with production
our goal is block excessive production
of Integrity into the cell surface so
but there's another another aspect
galactin 3 which which are really plain
Health Integrity the retain at the cell
surface and you can see there's a
boundary expressing different cancers so
foreign
structure
and on the cell surface of prostate
cancer on any cells Integris are
heterodimer having Alpha and beta
subdomains so mg85 glycosylation
associated with increase of galactin 3
because these glycans can recognize by
pentameric galactines so in other words
this
this whole place galactinsuline
techniques forming strong clusters of
integrines at the surface of uh cancer
cells using different combinations of
galactines integrine antibodies we did
comprehensive analysis of integrine
alpha v
immunoster chemistry and you can see
increase of production of integrines in
a non-metastatic prostate cancer but
what do we see mostly significantly we
see increase of intriguing alpha-v
expression in metastatic patients crpc
patients in both tissue and Bone
metastasis
uh and also this is a different kind of
Integrity we found in taking alphabetic
but the three is getting higher we
finally taking also we better seeks also
increase of integral so we better five
but we couldn't find we couldn't find a
difference in taking alphabet beta a so
basically different kind of integrine
alpha we better see better five can be
expressed so when it comes to the mg85
mediated glycosylation the question is
why in cancer cells instead of
activating mjh3 which is not oncogenic
at all we have activation of mg85 so the
clue comes from the understanding
because all these angle icons once these
glycos
glycosylated by mgh3s it cannot be
glycosylated by mg85 so forming
bisecting gluconnect is blocking mg85
glycosylation however and we believe
that all these uh compositions of
glycosyl transferences in relationship
with golgiomatics protein come from the
concept that uh enzymes are retaining by
complex formed between
graph 65 and gm130 Diamond one side and
giant in Diamond from other side so you
can see the atomic Force microscopy
found we can we can really find extended
genes and we can see hook giant it so we
like I told you before we believe that
Golgi this organization associated with
losses hook change instruction and then
uh in
without uh chanting
um without g130 Genting cannot function
at the golgiene indeed we knock down
giant we knock down sorry jn13 we can
see loss of giant in dimmer so all this
coming to the point that uh in lack of
mjt3 in the Golgi mg85 can be activated
normally both enzymes in the Golgi but
if it will come to the adenocarcinoma
prostitute of cancer you can see MGT
five still in the gold James history is
not so again this is a pla data showing
that giant and mg83 normally it's there
gojis in the Golgi however in prostate
cancer there's no interaction implying
that mg83 losing its Gold Gym or Golgi
localization and this is data from PC3
and d145 cells and you can see that
mg835 mj83 losing Golgi position and
contrary to mg85 so that's a concept gem
g83 using Jensen as a docking side mg85
using gn130 graph 65 when Golgi
disorganized Giant in dock inside
doesn't work mg83 cannot backend the
Golgi however mg85 uses an alternative
side still can that's that's the key why
mj85 glycosylation it's possible but
mg83 is not so this is a basic concept
of abnormal glycosylation you can see
that normally integrine is glycos
related by mjhc they don't form any
complex with galactin 3 and they barely
present in the cell surface they don't
form clusters however
mj85 glycosylation activated because
mgh3 shift into the ER and mg85
glycolated integrines can form clusters
with galactin-3 there is also
alternative password Gall T better 3 GMT
modified Integrity which also can form
with conductance I I simply don't have
time for saying that but the problem is
um
there's always two concepts that these
glycans which can simultaneously work
and express abnormally glycos related
integers but there's also interesting
aspects that high monos care integrines
which never been in the Golgi can be
moved to the uh plasma membrane via ER
plasma membrane Junctions so uh to look
at the electron microscopy images you
can see that normally you can see a
bunch of uh in taking clusters on the
plasma membrane however you always can
detect integrins in the ER plasma
membrane Junctions so by analyzing
um
uh so there's an effective tool when you
can treat cells with uh with glycosidase
and and only endoh enzyme can clear only
High monos glycans when we knock down
ATF C6 we can see uh you always presence
of high monos glycos which actually is
not present in ATF C6 knockdown uh
prostate cancer cells again implying
that ATF CTR stress responsible for
formation of these ER plasma membrane
Junctions so I'm going to give you
technical details how we measure these
and we come to the uh Point uh why uh so
what we use why a targeting Golgi is so
important so we use drug
hydroxychloroquine which you know
anti-malarial drug is which blocks out
of Aging we have phenomenon uh of
restoration of golgiomorphology after HC
treatment so hydroxychloro kind of
resource fragmented Golgi in both PC3
and D1 or 45 cells
so I cannot turn
fortunately into the next slide said
push to audience okay sorry uh okay so
we cannot restore golden morphology and
you can see fragmented Goji in PC3
control cells after hcqc Compact and
reorganize Golgi morphology so in
hydroxychloro can significantly reduce
integrine Alpha wave expression so
another word restoration of Golgi
associated with uh decrease of integral
Theory we create stable PC3 aj6
knockdown cells and you can see itself
with treated with hydroxychloro can show
most prominent effect on uh
integrine expression at the cell surface
and we did also approximately ligation I
say saying that hydroxychloroquine
reduce in taking Alpha vein galactin 3
Association and the plasma membrane and
this is the electron microscopy images
dual uh in taking Alpha V and galactin 3
in which shown that decrease only taking
Alpha V however we when we knock down 80
this is we see decrease in intriguing in
ER and plasma membrane Junctions so
um finally what we did we did orthotopic
tumor model when we injected mice with
PC3 control natives six knockdown says
in presence of hcq and you can see in
control mice you you always kind of take
a large tumor and original and
metastasis in organs so distant and
original metastases in hcq treated mice
you can see a smaller size of tumor but
it always kind of textile metastages and
lymph nodes and same is ATF six modern
however combined ntsc6 knockdown hcq
blocks progression significantly you use
the tumor sizes very low and we don't
see any metastasis and you can see
restoration of golgiene Vivo in this
species results and you can see decrease
of intriguing Alpha V expression so with
this we came to the basic constant We
Believe by treating with
hydroxychloroquine and restoring Golgi
we can reduce production of mg85
modified integrines by blocking atac6 we
can block production of high monos
integrines through ER plasma membrane
Junctions so uh and that's why we
believe our concept would be using
combination of HQ which is clinical uh
or clinically approved by FDA approved
drug using for patients but we block we
try to introduce adhd6 Inhibitors using
serpents so this will be our future
strategy to use sap in
to treat castration resistant prostate
cancer with this I like to just thank
all of my collaborators and my group
members for
there's different no collaborators from
International from UK and Russia so uh
with this I like to thank for your time
and I would be happy to answer your
questions please email me your questions
uh regarding what unfortunately I
skipped some important slide because of
time limit but I hope I send you a
message of what are we doing now and
what is the importance of uh Golgi
fragmentation phenomenon for prostate
cancer progression thank you